you've mentioned that you were always
curious about the physical world and
that uh an early question you remember
stood out where you asked your dad
why does ice float on water and he
couldn't answer and this was very
surprising to you
uh so you went on to learn why
maybe you can speak to what are some
early questions in math and physics that
really sparked your curiosity yeah
that memory is uh
kind of something i used to illustrate
something i think that's common in
science that people that do science
somehow have maintained
maintain something that kids always have
a
small kid
eight years old or so
uh
asks you so many questions usually
typically that you
consider them pests you tell them to
stop asking so many questions
and
somehow our system manages to kill that
in most people
so in school we make people do study and
do their things but not to pester them
by asking too many questions
and
i think
not just myself but i think it's typical
of scientists like myself that
have somehow escaped that maybe we're
still children or maybe we
somehow didn't get it beaten out of us
but i think it's
i teach in a college level and it's to
me
one of the biggest deficits is the lack
of curiosity if you want that we've
beaten out of them because i think it's
an innate human quality is there some
advice or insights you can give to how
to keep that flame of character i think
it's a problem of both parents and
and uh that parents should be should
realize that's a great quality we have
that you're curious and that's good
instead we have we have expressions like
curiosity killed the cat
and and uh
and more but i mean basically it's not
not thought to be a good thing you get
in curiosity kill the cat means if
you're too curious you get in trouble
and
uh i don't like catholics anyway so
maybe it's a good thing yeah yeah
that to me needs to be solved really in
education and in homes the
realization that there's certain human
qualities that we should
try to build on and not destroy one of
them is curiosity anyway
back to me in curiosity i was passed and
asked a lot of questions my father
generally could answer them
and at that age
and the first one i remember that he
couldn't answer
was
not a very original question but
basically that
is made out of water and so why does it
float on water
and
he couldn't answer it
and it may not have been the first
question it's the first one that i
remember and and that was the first time
that i realized that
to learn and answer your own curiosity
or questions there's various mechanisms
in this case it was going to the library
and
or asking people who know more and so
forth but
eventually you do it by what we call
research
but but it's um
driven by if you're
hopefully you ask good questions if you
ask good questions and you have the
mechanism to solve them then you do what
i do in life basically not necessarily
physics but
and it's a great quality in humans and
we should nurture it
do you remember any
other kind of in high school maybe early
college more basic physics ideas that
sparked your curiosity or mathematics or
science engineering i wasn't really into
science
until i got to college to be honest with
you
but
just staying with water for a minute i
remember
that i
was curious
uh
why uh what happens to water you know it
rains and there's water in a wet
pavement and then the pavement dries out
what happened to this
water that came down
and i you know i didn't know that much
and then eventually i learned in
chemistry or something water is made out
of hydrogen and oxygen those are both
gases so how the heck does it make this
substance that's liquid
[Laughter]
yeah but so that has to do with states
of matter
you've uh i know
perhaps ligo and
the the thing for which you've got the
nobel prize and the things much of your
life work
perhaps was a happy accident in some
sense in the early days but is is there
a moment where you looked up to the
stars and also the same way you wondered
about water
wandered about some of the things that
are out there in the universe
oh yeah i think everybody's
looks and is in awe and is curious about
what what it is out there and you know
and as i learned
more i learned of course that we don't
know very much
about what's there and the more we learn
the more we know we don't know i mean we
don't know what the majority of anything
is out there it's all what we call dark
matter a dark energy and that's one of
the big questions 20 year when i was a
student those weren't questions so we
even know less in a sense the more we
uh the more we look so
of course i think that's
one of the areas that um
almost it's universal people see the sky
they see the stars and they're beautiful
and
and see it looks different on different
nights and it's a curiosity that we all
have
what are some questions about the
universe
that in the same way that you felt about
the ice
that today
you mentioned to me offline you're
teaching um a course on the frontiers of
science frontiers of physics yeah what
are some questions
outside the ones we'll probably talk
about that kind of
yeah fill you with uh
get your flame of curiosity up and uh
firing up
yeah you know fill you with all
well first i'm a physicist not an
astronomer so i'm interested in physical
the physical phenomenon really so the
question of
dark matter and dark energy which we
probably won't talk about
are recent our recent their last 20 30
years or certainly dark energy
dark energy is a complete puzzle
it goes against what i'll
will what you will ask me about which is
general relativity and einstein's
general relativity it basically takes
something that he thought was
what he what he called a constant which
isn't and
and uh
in the if that's even the right theory
and it represents most of
the universe
and then we have something called dark
matter and there's good reason to
believe it might be an exotic form of
particles
and that is something i've always worked
on on particle accelerators and so forth
and it's a big puzzle what it is
it's a bit of a cottage industry and
that there's
lots and lots of searches
um but it may be a little bit like you
know looking for a treasure under rocks
or something you know it's hard to
we don't have really good guidance
except that
we have very very good
information that
is pervasive and it's there
and that it's probably particles small
that the evidence is all of those things
but then the most
uh logical solution doesn't seem to work
something called supersymmetry
and do you think the answer could be
something very complicated
you know i like to hope that think that
most things
that appear complicated are actually
simple if you really understand them i
think we just don't
know at the present time and it isn't
something that affects us it does affect
it affects how
the stars go around each other and so
forth because we detect that there's
missing gravity but
but it doesn't affect
everyday life at all i tend to
think and
expect maybe and that the answers will
be simple we just haven't found it yet
you